Росія передала міжнародній слідчій комісії додаткові дані з радарів, що стосуються катастрофи MH17.
Про це повідомила 24 серпня Генеральна прокуратура Нідерландів. Первинні дані, передані Москвою
восени 2016 року, не двалося розшифрувати через невідповідність форматів.
Офіційно Москва виступає за якнайповніше з'ясування правди про причини та обставини загибелі лайнера,
на борту якого 3 роки тому, у липні 2014-го, загинуло 298 людей.
Проте через рік після катастрофи Росія наклала вето на проект резолюції про створення спеціального Міжнародного трибуналу,
який мав притягнути до відповідальності винуватців авіакатастрофи. Як пояснив російський
представник в ООН - його країна має питання до неупередженості трибуналу.
Восени 2016-го Рада з безпеки Нідерландів завершила розслідування технічних обставин загибелі MH17. Вона дійшла висновку,
що літак збили ракетою класу земля-повітря "Бук" з території на південний схід від міста Торез. Майже одночасно Москва оприлюднила
свій власний звіт. Представники військового концерну "Алмаз-Антей" оголосили, що такої модифікації "Бука" на озброєнні російської армії
немає, і що ракету запустили з району, який могла контролювати українська армія.
Пошуком безпосередніх винуватців катастрофи займається Міжнародна слідча група, до якої Росія не приєдналася.
Коли восени 2016-го року міжнародне розслідування підготувало попередній звіт, за два дні до цього у Москві
знову скликали прес-конференцію - і оголосили уточнені дані своїх радарів. Які не виявили й сліду запуску ракети в районі катастрофи.
Росію попросили надати відповідні докази. Москва зробила це лише через місяць: у переддень парламентських слухань
у Нідерландах щодо МН17. Але ці дані виявилися в непридатному форматі: їх нереально було перевірити на неспотвореність, як і не можна було співставити
з іншими даними. Москву попросили надіслати дані ще раз, але у міжнародно визнаному форматі.
На це Росії знадобилося аж майже рік і от тепер вона нарешті передала додаткові дані радарів та інструкції розшифрування.
Попередні три роки розслідування причин катастрофи МН17 засвідчили, що російська влада не надає повної та своєчасної інформаційної,
експертної та технічної підтримки задля з"ясування обставин та винних у цій трагедії. Дії Москви радше блокують міжнародне розслідування.
Більше того, аби нівелювати вагомість висновків міжнародної слідчої групи, Кремль веде своє - альтернативне
розслідування, яке вже не раз розвінчували міжнародні експерти, зокрема з відомої платформи Беллінгкет.